well you're scouring through the
Commonwealth looking for loot caps and
bobbleheads you may come across a
traitor to sporting the vault 81
jumpsuit talk to them and they'll tell
you that they grew up in vault 81 you'll
get a marked in your map you may think a
working bolt now that's something you
don't hear about every day how did these
people survive the ordeal that vaulteq
must have set up for them so you make
your way to vault 81 and you're greeted
by their overseer who tells you to get
some fusion cores to be allowed in
fulfill this task and you gain access to
the thriving vault 81 looking like an
example of what everyone before the war
thought the vaults would be a community
working for each other they grow their
own food have those shops in a classroom
there's even a nice old lady making
sweets
it seems that vault-tec didn't perform
any crazy experiments here and the
people have lived contently for over 200
years this vault looks like paradise
it's a safe haven where you can get a
haircut
tell kids about your grand deathclaw
killing adventures and even relax with
some of grandmas home-cooked meals is
that really all there is to vault 81 the
vault Tec make a bolt with no hidden
intentions nothing to study maybe but
maybe not
after being in the vault long enough you
hear that one of the local kids Austin
is sick the resident junkie Bobby DeLuca
reveals Austin got bit by a mole rat
while checking out Bobby stash of drugs
this dash is near and apparently hidden
section of the vault one that no one
knew about except for Bobby he also says
that there's some notes about mole rat
diseases and vaccinations in this hidden
vault so you are tasked with going to
this secret vault and finding the cure
to Austin's illness and thus the real
darker side of vault 81 emerges follow
Bobby to the reactor room and he shows
you the door leading to the hidden side
of alt 81 but before heading on you may
notice a terminal off to the side marked
old overseers terminal this terminal is
master level so you're going to need
some pretty good hacking chops if you
want to gain access however if you can
break in the true identity of vault 81
becomes readily apparent this terminal
houses information for the first
overseer of vault 81 dr. Olivet inside
it you can find a plethora of
information about Olivet
Balt 81 and the plans baltic add for it
all of it was chosen for the position of
overseer through the skills in
administration and medical research
these skills were required due to the
nature of vault 81 s experiments secret
biological study of humans and the
creation of a cure for all diseases that
afflict them quite a lofty goal vaulteq
had in mind
Volta D ones prime directive of a cure
comes through three phases of clinical
trials first on petri dishes second on
heterosis glabrous vestments or
mole-rats provided by vault-tec and
third on the human residents of vault 81
all of these experiments were to be
carried out by a team of scientist
completely sealed off from the general
population inside the hidden vault
section of vault 81 these trials were to
give the scientists the information they
need to create a complete and singular
cure for all human diseases specifically
in a radiated world the general
population was to be disposed of via
incineration when given the vault-tec
all-clear signal now we can see the
dastardly vault-tec that were familiar
with
however Olivette isn't on board with
this plan what starts as concerned
quickly evolves into a full moral crisis
as Olivette realizes vault text true
intentions and how much influence the
company has with the United States
government so on the day the bombs fall
all of it
sabotages the phone list so that not one
scientist receives the call to head into
the vault yet three scientists Collins
Barone Flint still managed to make it in
by the time the vault door closes and
they begin their work right away the
last pieces of information exclusive to
this terminal are the personal logs of
Olivette it is from here that you get a
glimpse of the thoughts and motivations
behind vault 81 s first overseer from
the very start Olivet had worries about
the morality of vault-tec and this job
once all of it realizes what is really
going to happen a counterattack begins
Olivet prevents the scientists from
getting called in installs the three
that made it in for time as they blow
through phase one and two rapidly and
lastly all of that plugs the nozzles
that were meant to deliver the phase
three diseases to the general population
once burrowed
is this all of it ceases all
communication with the scientists and
leaves them isolated to their section of
the vault permanently they have food and
water to last they must remain by
themselves without any real goal in life
until they die
all of it hopes for forgiveness isn't
all of it doing what vaulteq was
sacrificing a few for the greater good
seems like the tables may have turned on
the suppose at righteousness of Olivet
now that you've gotten an idea for the
goals and history of vault 81 it's time
to actually head into the hidden side of
the vault upon entering you can see the
dilapidated state calls from almost 200
years of idle rocks and mud everywhere
several walls blown through this is
starting to look like most of the vaults
we've seen in the wastelands of Fallout
pretty soon you'll have your first of
many encounters with the special vault
81 mole rats more powerful and versatile
than your average horribly irradiated
post-apocalyptic mole rat following this
is a terminal giving a little more
insight into the mole rat research mole
rats were separated into different
colonies based on their aggressiveness
and some of the keepers even thought
that the mole rats were watching them as
of the start of the vault cures have
been developed to eliminate 36 percent
of known viruses up from previous years
33 percent which is actually pretty
promising
it seems that vault techs research was
actually getting some good results maybe
they would have actually succeeded had
not all of it
sabotage fault anyone's prime directive
continuing on some turret and
Protectorate defenses need to be
dispensed of it's really still a
surprise to me how these things have
power to run for two centuries and
looking through the broken and decaying
living quarters you can see how this
hidden vault was really supposed to be
just as much of a community as the other
side beds and dressers and tables and
even a small cafeteria just like the one
in the residential section of the vault
show that even though their goal was
research not simply surviving like the
residents the scientists were still
meant to live in prosper like normal
human beings instead almost all of them
were killed when the bombs fell the
final three were doomed to lonely deaths
soon after as you keep progressing
deeper into the vault you'll come across
many more mole rats that will attack you
on sight they're fairly tough for mole
rat
some taking multiple 50 caliber rounds
to be put down will you fulfill your
duties as de-facto exterminator another
very interesting aspect of the hidden
bulk should appear observation windows
there seems to be a one-way mirror and
terminal associated with some of the
important rooms in vault 81 the
hydroponics or farm room the general
store and even the overseers room have
windows and even a microphone speaker
set up to listen in on the conversations
of the residents the terminals keep the
scientists notes on how each room is
doing and what viruses would be good to
implement via that specific room even
with only three people the scientists
were getting a lot of work done after
the observation windows another living
area for the scientists filled with mole
rat follows though it appears that this
is the area where the mole rats were
held so the large numbers of them and
the brood mother's being here makes
sense
the important artifacts in this section
are a vault-tec chest and the research
communications terminal for dr. Collins
the chest has some typical loot
including a pretty cool mechanic's suit
which might entail that there weren't
only scientists destined for the hidden
section of vault 81 but also support
staff such as mechanics that were meant
to keep the hidden vault working for the
scientists those are even more lives
that possibly could have been saved had
all of it not sabotage the phoneless
moving to the terminal it archived
communications between dr. Collins and
the overseer elevate Collins messaged
Olivet questioning why so few scientists
made it to the vault and reporting
mechanical failures throughout the
hidden section of the vault which could
have been solved by those supposed
mechanics had they been there eventually
Colin realizes all Yvette's plan to
prevent their research and pleads for
response when all of it ceases all
contact
he doesn't even blame Olivet for
sabotaging the research conceding that
it is a breach of moral codes in the
world they used to live in but he just
wants a response rather than Olivet
hypocritically condemning the remaining
scientists to a solidary debt but all
event never responds and after bypassing
an expert level terminal you can see the
coffins of the three scientists
forgotten by the world and left to rot
in what ended up being their cell all of
it tried to sacrifice a few for the
greater good
exactly vault Texan tensions in most of
their vaults though that sacrifice might
have taken away a possible disease-free
future for Humanity Collins understood
this but couldn't do anything to
challenge it all he could do was
research mole rats and die but maybe
there's a redeeming Grace in all of this
turmoil near the locker coffins of the
three scientists a mr. handy robot named
Curie is locked in a room she calls out
to you to let you know that she has
finished the research of the deceased
scientists she has developed vault-tec
skull and end-all-be-all cure that can
remedy any disease known to mankind yet
she needs a vault-tec employee to let
her out of the room due to protocol let
her out and you received the final
product of vault 81 hidden section to
cure however the cure is only one dose
and cannot be recreated with the
materials around the cure to all human
disease we'll only have one usage
imagine if Olivet didn't do any
sabotaging perhaps the scientists could
have made a cure that's reproducible and
all the sickness in the human world
would simply cease to exist
vault-tec would have actually made a
successful experiment that benefitted
all mankind but that didn't happen
instead you must live in a
disease-ridden world
oh well looking into Curie's room you
can find the medicine bobblehead and two
terminals the first includes a vault 81
s mission statement revealing that
vaulteq explicitly acknowledged that the
needs of the many far away the needs of
the few
Olivette is almost a carbon copy of
vault-tec just without the bigger
picture the second terminal is curies
personal terminal she records
information about the three scientists
their personalities and their deaths dr.
Collins is the one that gives Curie the
terminal and gets the others to treat
her like a human he's also the one that
keeps burrows in Flint calm while trying
to deal with the overseer sabotage he
appears to be a leader looking out for
his team dr. Flint is objectively
brilliant and very brusque but a speech
is easy for curio to understand he's
straightforward burro is great to work
with he does tasks like manual labor
even though Curie can lift a lot more
than him due to being a robot so burrow
is doing this
out of human politeness and respect even
though Curie doesn't understand
Burroughs was the last to die due to a
heart attack before his death he
instructed Curie on his cremation and to
continue the team's research so that
their deaths wouldn't be in vain
she'd put him in place with the others
graves and respected their last wishes
she finished the Cure now the secrets of
vault 81 have been exposed head up to
the residential section of the vault and
choose if you want curie to be your
companion also decide if you're going to
take the Cure yourself and occur the
wrath of all 81 sweaters or save austin
kid they got sick do the latter and
you'll receive the love and acceptance
of all 81 and you'll even be gifted a
room in the vault so now you can see the
truth of vault 81 suppose to cure all
human diseases and partially succeeded
so ordered by the attempted
righteousness and supposed morality of a
conflicted overseer they caused many
more to die than need it this is an
unfortunate fault but definitely much
better than most others it still
produced a thriving community and did
succeed in making an all disease cure
who knows if without that one overseer
the world would be free from disease all
humans forgetting the looming worry of
sickness and fection in the already
daunting wastelands or maybe the
scientists did manage to infect the
humans of all 81 some hidden disease and
it has been carried on for generations
now extending throughout the
Commonwealth with unknown repercussions
and an unknown cure if it were ever to
become active again unfortunately we may
never know the answers to these things
but one thing we do know is the story of
vault 81
yo what's up everybody man Luigi here
and I hope you guys enjoyed the video
one thing I want to do right now is give
a huge shout out to the end
Apple here's an amazing fallout Laura
series and I highly suggest you guys to
check out some of his videos the idea
for this video came from when I was
watching a couple of his videos now I do
really hope you guys enjoyed this this
is out of my normal upload zone
I normally upload tips and tricks and I
thought a lower video like this would be
a really cool idea so I'm hoping it's
received well I'm hoping you'd like it
if you do like it you made all the way
to the end make sure you let me know
that you liked it that I should keep
doing more of these if you want to see
more of these or if not let me know so
that being said again thank you for
watching make sure to check out more on
my channel if you want more fallout 4
content I admittedly only have this is
my only lower video currently up so all
the other videos are going to be tips
and tricks so unfortunately if you want
more of this I don't have any that
however you can check out the entire
pool as I said because he hasn't a lot
of amazing fallout 4 and previous
fallout concepts alright guys thank you
for watching and peace have